Bill Clinton pressured Vanity Fair not
to write about Epstein new Doc's claim
an email from the newly unsealed court
documents reports quote B Clinton walked
into VF and threatened them not to write
about Epstein's sex trafficking yo uh we
actually have this the Calvin Kulu
project tweets out the email it says uh
good points all of them I'm looking at
both sides of the picture on the upside
I will give exposure to build up
publicity for the case etc etc we'll
skip over and then it goes uh goes down
to say uh let me find this point
it must be carefully written and not
give any Notions about the upcoming book
for any new info when I was doing some
research into Vanity Fair yesterday it
does concern me that they could want to
write about me considering that be
Clinton walked into Vanity Fair and
threatened them not to write about sex
trafficking articles and his good friend
Jeffrey Epstein should I be asking what
is this story uh their writing
pertaining to I just thank goodness for
having a friend like you on the inside
who knows how to deal with the
viciousness of today's world is another
email it's says I would let vity fa buy
your picture via Brad the big gamble
would be to let him also give the
statement saying your interviews with us
were accurately reported and you have no
more to say this time about how you were
trafficked to PA and other men including
two of the world's most respected
politicians redacted and redacted as
well as women the scenes with G Lan
because you are writing a book PA of
course prince Andrew and the the other
crazy thing is in the documents
yesterday there was a statement from w a
witness about who they had been
trafficked to and one of those names was
still redacted and the question is why
why why so you of course had prince
Andrew you had Jean Luke Brunell and
then there was a name that was redact
and everybody wants to know what was
that one name who do you think it was if
you had to put money on it Bill Clinton
yeah I feel like Bill Clinton is the
most obvious but you know fact the fact
is that it could be a lot of people
which is even more disturbing I I
disagree I I agree and disagree okay it
could be a lot of people Fair okay
that's that's obvious who knows right
but how is it that Jean Luke brunell's
name is released prince Andrew how is it
that a document release that's supposed
to have these names unrejected for
public interest one name still gets
redacted maybe they weren't informed
that they've been subjected to being
that they were called out by the
witnesses no that wouldn't matter there
there actually is a fairly easy and
obvious reason that would something that
would super a civil claim so you have
these documents journalists file a
lawsuit saying Freedom of Information
release the names the court says yes and
reds one name why National
Security what could supersede a lawsuit
on Freedom of Information that would
result in the documents being released
keeping one of those names covered up
national security reasons and that
person Stone office bin not no not still
in office the the the if if if that
comes out we know Clinton's named in
these documents but he's not named as
actually having done anything related to
trafficking just having been flying on
the plane and been around these people
and Jeffrey epon said Clinton likes them
young and now we're learning from the
latest document dump that Clinton uh
allegedly went to vity fair and tried to
cover up the Epstein story year was this
email oh let's let's pull let's pull it
out it's probably like uh what do we
have uh 2011 okay I mean none of this is
surprising at all who remembers when Amy
robach got caught on the hot mic talking
about how she had the story about
Epstein and that the her producer killed
it said she couldn't wasn't allowed to
do it right that was what 20 2015 or
something like that yeah there was a I
mean there was a long time where EP was
being covered up this is post one of his
sex offender convictions though right
like there was a time when everyone knew
that epine had history he had been
convicted in Florida and yet we still
weren't willing to talk about him it's a
very strange time some people think it's
Joe Biden that's this is my like current
theory that actually Joe Biden is is
going to be on the list I know we were
floating Hunter earlier before the show
but uh I think Joe Biden is sort of a
more precarious variable it can't be
because he was too long yeah it's too
long it's too long no no that's it Brett
Nails it take Hillary Clinton can it be
Hillary Clint Hillary Clinton no uh it's
not long enough so uh take a look at the
length of the black bar but that's not
what matters because when you're doing
redactions the the the the placement of
the redaction could be it's it's if
someone clicks it and drags it we don't
know we don't know like the same size as
prince Andrew that name but right so you
look at the commas of where it's placed
in the document because the spacing of
the text is not altered and then what
you can do is you can go from comma to
comma and you can actually determine how
many characters exist in this person's
name you don't know it could be three in
their first name and seven in the last
name or seven in their first name three
in their last name who knows but it
looks like it's about the length of
probably not John Luke Bernell that's
too long maybe though maybe though
prince Andrew Bill Richardson seems to
to to fit uh rather well in that spacing
we we know it's not I'm not saying it's
literally Bill Richardson I'm saying a
name of that size yeah those many
characters so uh it doesn't seem like it
would be Bill Clinton no dtz is named
outright in these documents so they
don't need to redact that and his name's
longer yeah uh I don't think Clinton
because if it said Bill Clinton you can
tell it would be shorter so not Bill
Clinton and it won't be Hillary right
Hillary I mean I doubt doubt what what
you never know she could be part of it
like these are guys right bang you
that's what I'm saying I this is me like
not looking at the email just like
depending on it I mean yeah you know
what I really want you know why I'm not
really like depending on the on the
documents cuz a lot of this is like
hearsay I really just really want to see
the the JP Morgan list and see who he
paid off cuz that's where you find out
where the real crimes were head in damn
maybe that's where Stephen Hawking is
maybe that's his name right there you
think that's enough letter I was very
sad that I didn't get to talk about the
step Hawking stuff last night Colin rug
tweeted this yesterday he said a single
name is redacted in a list of
individuals who gillain Maxwell
allegedly directed underage girls to
have sex with who is this person the
redacted name was next to former New Mex
Mexico Governor Bill Richardson
billionaire hedge fund manager Glenn
Dubin uh prince Andrew model Scout Jean
Luke Brunell and computer scientist
Marvin Minsky released the name I think
it's a national security thing prince
Andrew is not a national security issue
for the United States right I'm willing
to bet it could be someone who's
currently still in office but then you
saying like um is National Security that
means it has to be somebody current
because you Bill Clinton is over there
like it's has to be
current like like Clinton for former
president still have Secret Service yeah
and so they could they could argue that
like information retained by the
president could you like I mean they'd
say this like if a former president was
directly implicated in these documents
the National Security implications for
this country would be nuts treaties
could be at risk border disputes could
ignite anything Bill Clinton had done
could to unravel it could cause problems
in the stock market so absolutely you
could say Jimmy Carter for all we know
and they're going to be like no way but
I don't think it says bin I think the
redaction bar is too long the spacing is
too wide it says Joseph Biden Joseph R
Biden yeah but it would uh it's it's our
our Biden isn't it no what what what he
has more than one middle name doesn't he
one it's robertina something like that I
think it's just Joseph Robert Biden
Joseph R Biden really it's even worse if
the fact that they're a serving
president gets to keep them off the list
for and then using National Security as
a crappy
excuse I in this day age and oh you're
right yeah Joseph Robinette Biden Jr oh
yeah the junior so then I don't think
they'd use his middle his middle name
though and I think Joseph R Biden would
be too long yeah too and then he's
popularly known as Joe I think the same
way that they're listing you know they
hypothetically prince Andrew has a last
name too there's no reason to say Joe
Biden people are only saying Joe Biden
because he's a president right now right
and well one thing I can tell you we
know it's not Donald Trump for a fact
can it be Barack
Obama yeah Barack Obama may fit because
think about this is
2011 well Obama was serving as president
in 2011 this this document is actually
not this is 2016 yeah oh it's a 2016 so
the question is everything could be
unraveled and why is this Reed now
though uh I don't think Barack Obama no
no I have this weird thing I think
Barack Obama's into other things I don't
think I don't think this is kind of his
Jam is and this is I mean I flush the
the out totally right now I have to do
some research but prince Andrew Bill
Richardson they're actually closer in
age from what I understand Barack Obama
is slightly younger than them so there
is sort of a a similar age group of
people that means they were running
similar circles barck in some ways was
sort of outside that and I think he has
different
proclivities I can't speculate on his
proclivities partially because my mind
would be I'm half joking actually and
I'm sure like the chat is just igniting
over what that means about bar my mind
thinking like the him and the guy at the
bar yeah I'm just thinking that National
Security and I'm just trying to think
who worked in Obama's administration
that's now working in um tons of them
the thing
Obama is heavily staffed by former
got not high enough Prof doesn't need to
be a president it can it it be it could
be like a dude named like John Jackson
his name is redacted because he worked
for the CIA but like if you could think
of like what's his name um Secretary of
State um damn it just um blinkin
that's National secur it does say on the
next line another Prince like there's
prince Andrew John lell Bill richardon
another Prince which one somebody named
this Prince wow really another Prince
the petty little one or the one that
does know what briti how wait wait that
that's actually a really good point
nobody pointed out says other than Glenn
du uh glin Glen duin redacted prince
Andrew John Luke reell Bill Richardson
another Prince the large Hotel chain
owner and Marvin Minsky is there anyone
else what do you mean another
Prince asked who that yeah that's my
breaking news journalism who because the
thing is second Prince and it doesn't
have to I mean like the the queen of
Denmark just announced kind of abruptly
on New Year's Day or Eve that she was
going to going to resign so there's this
moment where I'm like is it someone in
the Danish monarchy cuz there are
princes there like her her son the
prince is about to become king like I
I'm not here to slender him I'm just
saying hypothetically we're thinking
British Monarchy but there are tons of
princes out there how come nobody and
nobody's not famous like the Brothers I
didn't I didn't even realize this
princesses nobody cares about royalty
the way I do but no that's true that's
but but I like the Queens who's the
large Hotel chain owner I mean that's
also interesting right like what's his
name Cass matiz because he's a really um
John CES CU
he and he donated to a lot of
Republicans and Democrats M he's he's
what a billionaire based out New York
his daughter's like the the chair of the
New York Manhattan Republicans I just
think I'm like I don't look look look
Colin Colin rug tweeted this and he's
like who's the redacted name and I'm
like who is this other prince who the
now we got this Prince yeah but then
maybe if we knew who the red acted name
was we might also know who the other
prince was right like it what if it said
like an and an artist formerly known as
prin that's what I said is as long as
it's not it's long that it can't be that
as long as Minnesota isfe leave
Minnesota out of this I don't want any
bment to his
name okay check it out uh someone
actually did the work they said using C
year new the redaction is 16 characters
long now everyone's going to be sitting
here like the best cross puzzle ever I
know right I was like can we just play
Tex now
yeah interesting now people will have to
start uh looking at politicians and
getting characters uh character limits
on all of their names so they can start
putting them in there to see who it ends
up being to I I I think it's important
to point out however cross it's the name
has 15 characters because there's a
space between the first and second and
last name uh there's one
there's one uh Source reporting or one
publication the messenger reporting that
one of the victims said she had sex with
Hyatt hotel's billionaire Tom pritsker I
thought it was pritsker I thought it
might be pritzker that's probably wait
the brother the the brother of um
Chicago um Chicago Governor I mean not
Chicago Illinois governor I they're
related but yeah he's they're related I
mean no I don't know they but that
family is real estate then that brings
in Obama because again illino got it
you heard it here first ladies and
gentlemen his sister worked in the Obama
Administration um all right here's what
we're going to do we've got the power of
45,000 people right now ladies and
gentlemen a name with 15 characters okay
so it's it's 16 total characters but we
assume there's a space there because I
doubt whoever they're naming goes like a
single name because usually single names
are small like Bono but uh we've got so
so someone who's got a name with 15
characters and I know between the 45,000
people someone can figure it out or at
least make some good guesses so uh crowd
sourcing good luck crowd sourcing
prominent high-profile individual here
here's what we're thinking someone who
has the ability to get a foyer request
release redacted still this potentially
could be one of the Doe's that has
requested so let's take a look at who
are the remaining people that have got a
stay on their names being released it
could be that the name was not released
because they've got an appeal but then
we're going to know which do John do or
Jane do it is who's getting that delay
is it possible that they're rejecting
the name because that person is
cooperating with whatever investigation
but is in the investigation kind of
mostly over
I no okay this is not an investigation
this was a civil lawsuit for defamation
it never actually went anywhere it was
settled out of court the documents get
released and now people are speculating
as to the criminal elements that may
have may be involved in this
so my my first speculation is is I would
say this in in starting the
investigation the Assumption I would
make is something related to National
Security allowing the name to remain
redacted so we're thinking uh law
enforcement
politics uh you know like law
enforcement intelligence agencies uh it
it could be however also related to
those who requested a a an extension on
having their name remain redacted
so this is here's the important thing
the people who said that uh uh there's
the Jane do 107 saying don't release my
name cuz I live in a conservative
country and it'll be bad news for
me these are accusations of child
trafficking yeah who would get who could
get their name redacted and prince
Andrew couldn't prince Andrew could not
get his name withheld from this but this
person could but didn't his family um
excommunicated him sure sure but still
say before all this happened they
excommunicated him that's why they were
able to release his name like that am I
wrong in thinking that he already faced
a lawsuit in in England about it so in
some ways like his connection to this
you were right about the prit by the way
uh JB PRK related to the Hyatt Family
yeah the only reason I knew about that
is when um that Harvard thing and then
apparently the sister is in the board
yeah and I was like when I started like
trying to like find out who's connected
to who a lot of them are like Democratic
donors and RV Weinstein fits people are
pointing out but I I why would he be
redacted exactly he would not be of all
the people he's the least likely to be
redacted so I'm that's why thinking like
but I'm Ling former FBI CIA
guys that worked in the Clinton
Administration Obama administration even
Bush Administration bush had a bunch of
Democrats so I mean theoretically that
would be military then right there are a
couple different military like secret or
heads of military organizations that
have carried over through several
administrations yeah but no I was just
thinking about like think of like the
guys who worked in the CIA worked in the
heads of the CIA FBI to be like National
Security thanks for watching this clip
from from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
Tim cast.com for uncensored membersonly
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next
time